ok google est ce que je vais avoir mon
bac ça c'est bien la question du moment
en tout cas
cyrus nord ça m'a raconté une histoire
qui fait relativiser le stress des exams
un jour svt je sors mon manuel sauf que
la prof à nous 50 rôle du coup je prends
mes copies doubles mais brouillon etc
mais j'oublie venger manuel le contre
eux commencent mais si la prof me voile
orangé elle va crois que j'ai triché
du coup il rassure mes genoux gars très
sympa à la fin elle ramasse les copies
et le bois on se dévisagent ce théorème
elle savait que j'étais assez bonne
élève et j'avais dit que je ne l'avais
pas utilisé à fait pour rien et elle
continue de ramasser les copies je ne
sais toujours pas si elle m'a cru mais
je suis bien content d'avoir pu gagner
sa confiance
je vous explique pourquoi chez dans
l'assistant google à la fin de la vidéo
you et bonjour a tous bien dans cette
vidéo explications du rap kg 3 donc si
vous êtes assez que vous avez sûrement
vu leur pio 3 si vous l'avez pas vu
alors pilot 3 on vous invite évidemment
à l'écouté c'est que du plaisir pour les
oreilles et vous comprendrez pourquoi on
boit de la limonade
on se demande vraiment pourquoi donc ça
est très vite mais c'est une vidéo qui
peut quand même vous servir
et puis moi je vais aussi redirigés vers
d'autres trucs qui sont sur la chaîne
parce que vu qu'il ya plein de guinée
soit gêné il ya pas de formats
différents t'aidera ça va être le moyen
aussi de s'y retrouver si vous passer le
bac notamment
ça peut vous aider mon nom pèse dans
tout pile au game car j'ai mis en place
tout un système
en fait il ya un philosophe qui a mis en
place vraiment tout un système on n'a
pas tant que ça il ya notamment eagle et
aristote qui ont mis tout un système qui
se répondent et caetera et qui ont
synthétisé tout ça les textes originaux
à lire sont très difficiles c'est chaud
à lire et en plus on a vu que tout les
systèmes et ses arrières forcément une
complexité qui fait que la même ce truc
de dialectique peu genre t'as synthèse
c'est la thèse d'une autre antithèse qui
a donné une autre synthèse cette
synthèse n'a pas tout et comme tout se
mêle et floirac beaucoup trop
intelligent me fatigue ça se déploie
comme ça et genre c'est sauf on ne se
pose quant aux opposants du coup ça
c'est une côte est là et à la fameuse
d'éthique du maître et de l'esclave que
je parais expliqué petit déjà parlé
aussi dans cette même vidéo sur eagle
path enchaîne avec qui après c'était au
montaigne tout simplement montagne en
montagne il est connu pour plusieurs
choses la première chose que je
mentionne moi c'est de l'amitié avec la
boétie et c'est vrai que c'est étonnant
de pas quand on parle d'un philosophe
dire bâti un premier truc connu sur lui
doivent et un pote non c'est à dire que
en fait c'est rare oui s'il use of force
et c'est déjà ce n'était pas n'importe
quel poste puisque etienne delà de la
boétie a écrit 18 ans le discours sur la
servilité volontaire un truc comme ça
j'avoue j'ai pas il a écrit notamment
une phrase décidé tirant son grand c'est
parce que nous sommes à genoux devant
eux à cela vaut aussi à 18 ans après
tout que ce que faisais tu as 18 ans est
donc cet ami dit elle aussi mental parce
que montagne c'est un relativiste et
cette amitié avec le beau et si c'était
le seul la chose un petit peu absolue
qu'il est connu à dire que quand il
essaie de justifier ça ça fait partie
citation j'utilise ma parce que c'était
lui parce que c'était moi c'était comme
ça c'était une évidence une sorte de
l'idéal donc il ya cette amitié c'est
impossible je pense de résumer les
essais en tout cas moi j'ai regardé ça
aborde tous les sujets il a sorti des
phrases ans qui sont un peu des
punchline que je utilises tu sais mieux
vos têtes bien faites côté de bien
m philosopher c'est apprendre à mourir
bim punchline ça fait partie des
philosophes rappeur et l'art la
punchline c'est sûr le beau de plus beau
au trône du monde on n'est jamais assis
que sur son cul
j'ai dit que c'est un relativisme voilà
le mec nous relativise tout belle leçon
belle île et c est tout un party
importante aussi que je traite sur la
gloire la recherche de gloire qui est un
frein à la tranquillité et la quiétude
et par conséquent ce bonheur da cruz si
tu veux plaire tu es mal barré pour pour
être heureux le troisième philosophe
c'est une troisième philosophe à une
femme c'est la seule femme en 18
philosophe de trois pylônes harel elle
est très connue pour notamment son étude
du tourisme du totalitarisme allemand
des juifs qui né en 1906 à écouter la
chance de s'en sortir elle s'est
notamment barré à cette eau est elle a
réfléchi à tout ça et je trouve que là
la réflexion intéressante parce qu'elle
est pas dans quelle est la première
chose qu'elle veut c'est comprendre et
donc elle va au procès je crois c'est
rischmann
jerusalem vous qu'à l'écrire livre
s'appelle ont fait ça de mémoire et elle
essaie de comprendre là comment est ce
qu'on peut en arriver là
parce que derrière tout système la mise
la généralisation du meurtre de meurtre
de masse de l'exécution c'est des gens
peu qu'il a priori tu vas voir n'importe
quel gars tu livres y ça te dirait toi
tu es 10 millions de personnes la
plupart des gens vont dire non et c'est
ce qui est intéressant c'est que kembo
elle décortique comment un système peut
faire que les gens deviennent des pions
et des simples exécutants exécutants et
entre guillemets des concitoyens
cinquante et un bon citoyen battue at
arrêté au feu au feu rouge et ya passé
au feu vert mais voilà quand tu étais un
bon citoyen tu disais ah bah tiens lui
le telle ethnie ou de telle confession d
l'orientation sexuelle alors on va
l'emmener dans ce camp et donc c'était
des gens qui faisaient des micros actes
il y avait des gens et les manquements
les démences décision mais c'est avec ce
la raison pour laquelle des millions de
gens ont participé surtout connu pour sa
jauge peut-être qu'avec elle a bossé sur
autre chose la moralité de sa recherche
sécu ces mecs là bas ils sont quand même
responsable d'avoir été couillon sud des
ordres sans se poser la question de la
finalité et voire même simplement est-ce
que c'était bon à court terme de faire
quitter oui c'est la phrase n'a pas
besoin d'être le diable pour être
capable du pire
c'est moi les mecs c'est vrai que je
possède un certain panache
un flou un flou j'ai envie de dire
lauzon d'ailleurs c'est rare les gens
qui sur ma chaîne font des jeux de mots
plus pourris qui est bien là bas ça me
fait plaisir et ça fait plaisir aussi
bonjour ans aveugle aux échos ou par
pourri sabri ben oui alors oui oui on
est fan on est fan du jeu de mots vaseux
m
on adore ok après ça enchaîne avec
sénèque
alors je n'ai pas quitté le contemporain
jésus-christ et willy lennon 4 il est
néanmoins 4 - un peu pas trop
ouais et il est mort en 65 et que
sénèque c'est une figure du stoïcisme
qui est cette philosophie du bonheur qui
vise à atteindre l'ataraxie via la cèze
donc ce travail sur soi pour se détacher
de certains désirs qui ne dépendent pas
de soi et c'est un machin travail la
modération bénisse tous les pays mais en
fait c'est pas ça non on va essayer ça
passe tout seul sur une chaise à
regarder un mur blanc ouais et c'est
vrai que même dans le vocabulaire
d'aujourd'hui être stoïque moratti
commerces et petites
si vous aviez assez connu oui je sais
pas ce que c'est un miss dessus john
locke
alors lui c'est l'empirisme l'empirisme
qui s'opposent à 10 des aliments
idéalisme c'est en gros c'est l'éternel
débat entre l'inné et l'acquis et la
théorie principale de john locke que ses
intérêts de mme merkel le point jean loc
c'est de dire que en gros quand on
aimait et naïveté on arrive avec le
disque dur vide c'est à dire on n'a pas
des idées préconçues ya pas de guide et
universel qu'on va retrouver à travers
l'histoire à travers les peuples et qui
vont se révéler qui dit voilà l'homme à
sa naissance c'est une tabula rasa une
table rase et
terre brûlée ardoise vierge et nous pas
un taboulé vraiment c'est ainsi voilà un
taboulé rasade c'est une très bonne
entrée de mes roses ouais bon moyen de
retenir retenir un tabou les roses la
boule et rose et sabu les rosés le bon
apéro bonnafé roger leborne apporter
empiriste le taboulé rose donc tabula
rasa tu es quand même tu es quand même
un tueur est à mettre un baume et puis
après avec le temps et ben on va
comprendre des choses on va faire des
connexions comme on fait cette connexion
bas par l'expérience qu'on dit qu'on n'a
pas de deux choses qui sont affrontés
divine qui vient alors ça ne plaisait
pas de coup beaucoup à à ses détracteurs
des cartes leibniz et spinoza qui eux
avec l'expérience révèle des choses non
qui est de la connaissance en vivant et
les choses de manière empirique donc un
nom puristes et notamment tu acquiers
cette connaissance via les sens ça c'est
en tout cas important oui et ton
expérience on fait du coût via le prisme
de désensibiliser soit idée si trompeur
puisse-t-il être etc
alors là je vais me servir un petit un
petit peu de la monade tu as bien raison
2010les vlad limmat
l'ailé volante la cngs limonade de
l'élite
la meilleure technique quand tu lourd là
si je si je vous en parle trop je veux
dire de la merde quand j'en ai fait j'ai
fait une vidéo à sa fille que j'ai tapé
mot par mot chaque mot et penser chaque
mot est pesé même
donc je vais pas grosso modo une
histoire comme donc de substances qui
déterminera si tous ces composés
substance et ça se sent ça une brique de
base il dit parce que voilà la tombe
physique on connaît en plus il est fait
encore de matières etc c'est un machin
je le truc de base de base et ça cet
atome métaphysique
c'est la monade je veux pas partir des
militants d'un pro / sur l'as monaco est
prise enfin si tu peux fait le haut
comme d'habitude oui mais tu es caca
prout encore expliqué la monade allez
bon courage c'est clair non mais c'était
un plaisir en tout cas en baroeul
c'est pv qui lui voir gt gt je passe en
tête
on a fait rap et des gens qui avait
l'art de la punchline puivif mine de
rien ça donne envie de creuser parce que
voilà nous ce qu'on fait c'est
superficiel mais ya rien de mieux que de
lire ce que eux ont écrit je connais des
gars qui sont vraiment dans la ville aux
états qui diront si tu veux vraiment
comprendre un texte vraiment travailler
à plusieurs
tu dois lire le texte de base sans
traduction qu'ils apprennent l'allemand
pour pouvoir lire du hegel ou du doigt
quelque part ils ont raison c'est voilà
donc entre ça est ce que nous ont fait
il ya quand même 50 nuance de grecs
tamara la lumière pièce je le micro si
je couperai chao vu qu'il ya le bac j'ai
l'opportunité de donner quelques
anecdotes à l'assistant google et donc
c'est ouf
il suffit de dire ok google est ce que
je vais avoir mon bac et ensuite je suis
plus prêt vise aucun goal de prévisions
stop
ok google aime la lumière compris
j'allume les trois lumières
donc voilà n'hésitez pas à retrouver
d'autres anecdotes je vous mets un lien
en descriptions il n'y a pas que mes
anecdotes il ya aussi celles de deux
autres youtuber donc ne soyez pas
surpris
jamais j'aurais pensé que ma voix se
retrouve dedans donc c'est à souffle
comme expérience
merci beaucoup merci encore bonjour
normalement dimanche pour une nouvelle
vidéo qui n'a rien à voir et qui est
assez importante
donc j'espère que vous serez au rendez
vous ceux qui passent le bac n'hésite
pas aussi à checker la chaîne de
l'antisèche c'est une chaîne où j'ai
fais vraiment tous les contenus pour le
bac brevet et bach lien description
allez-y c'est pas encore fait love peace
ciao